welcome to this video playing Grand
Master goldmund he's not playing often
these days this is um Alexander I think
Alexander writer lost em off like son
dollars they were pretty strong rent
master um Spiller who's seen been a ruse
at the moment for some reason ok we have
got the two nights line of the comic con
then play the Bronstein large Jack again
haven't played it for a while i am from
had a decent results with it it's not
it's not brilliant but i had some some
good games also some pretty drastic
losses but I don't know this this kind
of setup doesn't look so troublesome to
me ok so he's maybe plane came let's
let's let's consider let's consider for
a moment if I go Quincy seven and he
goes c5 I can't play Bishop f4 so isn't
isn't dumb a big issue okay
yeah yeah young hmm I just forgot about
this move aha and this is quite
embarrassing because what else really
Wow Gladys is really looking better
already so very very unfavorable break
here in the center and we're smoking
going I if I've looks looks like crap
but whatever what else should I play
yeah maybe this opening is simply a bad
idea against good players I mean really
good players okay maybe it's not a
matter of the opening is a matter of
knowing it and I certainly don't know it
well enough to employ it against a good
GM like like roast em off Wow
can we have six I have Bishop e7 picking
up the noid yeah yeah I am what I want
what else yes you can just just do
whatever you wish yeah it's a it's it's
simply bad now aged 70 is just like all
night cya can you can just take age 7
ounces quite simple I cannot castle long
him
yeah so I forgot I can he can also just
take him yeah in fact what if he could
have played Queen edge eater now i can i
can castle we just still still lost but
I thought Queenie jade was even stronger
but maybe maybe the student really
matter la
how many ponds I'm to upon stone right
hmm yeah it's not just the the pawns so
the position is just just damn ugly now
it should be three yeah
maybe I should have taken on be too
Queen Bee joke why not my advice I
didn't take them I mean it'sit's lost
right okay but if I'm not resigning of
them obviously not resigning at the mood
I can at least try to to to use some
chances that he might earn might give me
that's just stupid
look see seven others just it just he
six
maybe maybe it doesn't 86 he just takes
takes Queen you one so the only know
it's it's not working anyway check time
morning
yeah that's not even even if I had rook
h8 it's nothing okay vacuum black resign
as this opening I cannot play some play
against a good player and even i know i
know that the line that you played isn't
even particularly great but if I don't
if I don't know what to do it it's not
helping maybe even but should be six is
already a problem I mean how do i
prevent that I me here can take and play
97 which is probably better but this
this already looks like it's completely
unplayable this position maybe this one
yeah this is actually ok this I can do
as I can do my day 6 is a good idea at
least that trying something if it takes
which is a problem mistake i can i can
cancel long with this idea yeah maybe
something like them I don't really know
that opening too well I had some I've
made this video series for the SSC but I
forgot some of the stuff that I
recommended the way it went down it was
simply simply a crush with no play
whatsoever ok thanks for watching